with his remains now back in Iran the
numbers on the streets looked genuinely
remarkable this is a country which has
ways of ensuring the desired image is
presented and it is a regime under
pressure at home but still this was
quite a display as the images were
broadcast live iran's Foreign Minister
on Twitter was goading the American
president have you ever seen such a sea
of humanity in your life mr. Trump he
said do you imagine you can break the
will of this great nation and its people
the star speaker was the assassinated
generals daughter crazy Trump arrogance
and plaything of Zionism don't think
that everything is over with my father's
martyrdom my father had a father who
stood by his side and we too like our
father will stand by him the country's
supreme leader Ayatollah Khomeini led
the mourning Soleimani was effectively
his right-hand man his foreign policy
enforcer his death certainly impacts
Iran's strategic capability for now but
at what cost
the grief followed the coffin to the
holy city of calm this will continue to
gather in momentum ahead of the burial
in the hours ahead in Baghdad where he
cultivated the government and where he
died Iraq's top politicians and former
leaders met for a service of condolences
for the killing the Prime Minister spoke
by phone to Boris Johnson who urged him
not to expel British soldiers from the
country they are there to train Iraqis
trying to defeat Isis he also met the
UN's Iraq representative behind the
smiles and the phone calls though we
have no idea if anything positive
emerged what is clear is that America's
deep footprint across the region is now
at risk long term but short term two
embassies are under imminent threat of
attack they are already fortresses but
here in Beirut the Americans know that
even fortresses can be hit
in 1983 two bombings at the embassy and
a Marine barracks killed 258 Americans
Iran's proxy here Hezbollah is widely
believed to have been responsible and
across the cities Hezbollah
neighbourhoods soleimani is now mourned
in the next few weeks we will see it
unravel further Mohamed hajjali
specializes in analyzing Hezbollah Iran
and their relationship but the question
is if the Iranians are going to launch
an attack assay on the US bases on us
tubes hidden in a wok or elsewhere in
the region you know how would the u.s.
respond would they respond anyone or
will they respond with any water for the
Iranians proxy conflicts are about
keeping the conflict away from Iran's
borders keeping it away from Iran using
other battlefields other populations in
the conflict rather than having a direct
confrontation of the u.s. because they
would lose in a direct confrontation of
the US the American rationale for the
assassination was to disrupt Iranian
influence and meddling across the region
but that influence has become so
ingrained over decades that Iran can now
use its vast network to threaten America
on multiple fronts with this authorized
mass movement of grief it feels like the
Iranian regime is committing itself in
its people to a firm reprisal but what
and what then mark stone Sky News in
Beirut